hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until done also
known as butterfly effect the game
apparently the soul of discretion
ashlee encouraged Matt to use the
telescope Matt saw Mike and Emily
flirting I don't know
was that really flirting though Emily
seems like a mega [ __ ] Matt saw and
Matt confronted Mike therefore that's
all there is to that whose side are you
on
Matt sided with Emily during the fight
with Jessica and the result of that has
not seen itself being played out so now
we're going up to this secluded cabin
for a little hanky-panky I have a
feeling they're gonna be the first to
die in this game I mean I don't really
wonder if like what they have just died
from that icicle both of them somehow
magically I highly suspect maybe not did
you I didn't have an idea about that
hang on wait I think I got this I got it
got it got it
BAM huh does good one that's a good one
that's good one okay like backwards and
forwards at the same time let's go and
the only cure is mark cowbell more Bell
something that was that picture
important was that somehow important to
everything okay cool this subtle
flirting is not something I appreciate
Oh hmm well maybe it's because people
died and there's a mysterious murderer
afoot
is there another totem on the ground
somewhere that I need to know about
anybody anywhere any of you know what's
gonna happen
have I made the wrong choices already
the answer is probably yes
dumbest she looks if she thinks she can
cut in on what we got going on where
this come from
Emily was being a [ __ ] I think you
bring out the worst there is that sound
okay cool
that was a little weird don't know why
that was that thing that it was wait do
I have to - wait does this go to the I
think that okay I think the generator
might be over here you generate it might
be able to yeah unless this is the
romantic secluded cabin I have no idea
if it actually is oh boy
premonition I still haven't seen whether
Emily I think it was gets burned alive
okay I'm just gonna ignore that I ever
saw that might keeps what Mike sees to
Mike self Mike doesn't tell nobody that
don't need to know about Mike's troubles
okay thanks Mike right I flipped a
switch and I pulled a knob I'm a wizard
know something about that hello Jess
okay then I guess we're just gonna
pretend that never happened just go
about our day all willy-nilly as if
everything is just hunky-dory and
nothing is actually bad
yeah that's not hard to climb over oh
thank you yes I'll do everything yeah
you're one of those people that plays
music on their phone walking around in
the speakerphone terrible terrible
people just the worst kind of people I'm
kind of psyched cuz I'm perfectly I
level with your ass but that's not what
I've been tending to do it's just how
the trail is not looking at anything
well or anything for that's the thing
well I never closed the investigation
okay I'm getting the creeps now let's
see what do you remember yeah that'd be
more interesting it's all such a bar
you barely even remember what happened
well it was your fault I remember is
that we played us dupit half-baked prank
that probably got Hannah and Beth killed
hey I mean it's not our fault they ran
into the wood yeah how could anyone have
expected them to do a dumb thing like
that whoa I ruined the mood
well I'm sorry gosh I can't believe it
this reminds me a lot of coal lot by the
way just the wind or landscape I mean
there's obviously more people in this
one then : Shawn beam is narrating
everything in the game well I'm not
gonna get the choice to go back I kind
of think it might be a good idea to go
back but Mike don't back down for Mike's
potential
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's see I'll jump down well methinks a
murderer might be doing some bad okay
sir yeah don't help it I got it I got it
[Laughter]
why is when she's laughing and smiling
she looks like she's crying and this
looks like a lovely mine why is this
here
excuse me Jess now time for the bump and
grind yet excuse me thank you
yes all looks very sinister very bad
very no good yeah
why didn't you move out of the way your
Diouf getting a little too old being a
spry 28-year old high schooler I can't
take punishment like that anymore
Willy what are the good kind of willies
there's a wet willy CBGB Willy Willy but
gee will gee willikers that's another
one all right let's see what this is
this looks white so maybe it's a luck
token
that didn't look like luck a fortune
that didn't look like fortune at all
that looked bad what the hell is that
supposed to be I didn't see anything
what happened what happened I missed it
what happen what happened I didn't see
nothing I saw less than nothing
okey all right then weird why I have a
devotee I wonder if at this point I
could have already lost some people I
mean I'm willing the best if she would
have pushed the cart Mike would have
been gone
I hope I'm playing this the right way
but maybe note maybe my heroism will not
pay out for me hello oh this looks good
anybody being up here is a bad thing why
not go back no one should be up here how
clear is that mystical symbols like
historical yes but I don't think miners
were getting there arts and crafts on
now there's something trying to what
good question let's wait until they stab
us in the back to discover who knows
what's gonna happen all of my alarm
bells are yeah oh yeah especially now
that we don't have the path back to the
cabin okay is there anything over you oh
let me just walk into a pole for a
little bit hello
shallots bad place a real fixer-upper
okay so this is danger where are we
where where are we on this map I don't
know what any I don't know am I supposed
to I don't know
wait okay so if we came down the main
thing with the rail and we took a left
so we just gotta not go this does now
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die we're gonna
die Jess we're gonna die I hate
something for it to be this way but
titties oh crap
how am I supposed to know hey I'm Jess
hi I mix I want to make sure we don't
die holla'd the hell okay so there's two
paths branching off forward and right
which technically means we might be
okay collapse supports that might be
where we are the collapse support area
so if we go down this hallway and go to
the right it's gonna be bad but if we go
to the left it'll be slightly less bad
okay I think that's where we are but I'm
not a hundred percent on that one this
ain't good
this ain't good we're gonna die we're
gonna die we're gonna die oh we're gonna
die oh we're gonna die oh we're gonna
die look like hope that looks like death
hard yes we might die okay I guess we're
trying then oh never mind we're cool so
now what how are we gonna get back to
the other dudes and chicks bro huh how
are we gonna get our porn star party on
is anything over here guys wait up I got
a look at stupid [ __ ] for a few more
minutes before I'm ready to go okay
ready come on baby let's go bang let's
go big bang sexy coals and make a baby
anybody gonna get away my bang better
bring that over here okay
whoa all right hey just saw someone at
the cabin
huh
I don't see nobody whoa wake up pretend
that never happened
what the hell am I looking at here okay
so how do we turn back and go home can
we turn back and go home oh just us up
here maybe
can we turn around and go home I have a
bad feeling about this
yes stay close by okay what's that this
posting says there's some brown bears up
here sometimes that deer does not look
okay we should post it to the Bears this
is way back or forward okay good to know
I'm the world's slowest at opening
things this is death who's walking into
death a whole lot of death where are we
walking into death I can't go back we're
gonna get straight into death
or legit anyone gets in the way of me
banging with death you're gonna go and I
ain't coming to them I don't like this I
don't like the music did the orchestra
bump down a little bit hello Kim the
game stop doing movie things I was just
flirting yeah so let's go back I was
looking at the caribou this game needs
to stop being a 90s horror movie uh-huh
I'm nowadays horror movie pretty much
hello anybody up here anybody at all
anybody nobody all alone probably not
murders lots of murderers how do you've
done that you got a better idea
stand back debbie downer whoo no we
won't be able to be back no not this new
ball Wow that killed a bird don't you
know put rocks in it
yes oh okay I guess we'll just leave it
there then no big deal I'll be get the
fire going baby in my pants for the porn
party
anybody want pants invitation to the
porn party best not to check out best to
turn around and ignore it for a while I
better go back there was some strange
noises coming from over here
who'll be banging who will be banging
over here is enemy baby banging with
unprotected sex calls irresponsible teen
sex is the leading cause of death in
horror movies and life
okay nothing
I'll just sassy walk my way back out of
here it wouldn't be so cold if I wasn't
such a hipster I love this plaid skirt
only I could grow a beard be full-on
hipster okay never mind it's gonna look
over there not go there
Wow wander this way a little bit
ignoring all the weird white stains on
the ground okay I seem to be lost where
I am probably going out of my mind oh no
goody this is not where I wanted to go
that is creepy
Jenny do we used to do it all the time
man well Josh no hot waters kind of a
major oversight yeah douche yeah you
just gotta fire up the boiler it's in
the basement all right you guys see if
you can find this why are they gonna
make out you're not gonna it's right by
the condoms okay anyway so let's go turn
on the boiler
let's not check in on demo banging away
over there they're probably dead already
why is it in horror movies that the
villains never like anyone to get
romantic with each other in any way
can't happen no matter what I mean in
Jason it was explained because when
Jason drowned the camp counselors were
off banging and not watching the water
so that was understandable I guess
mission together I was thinking they
could use some alone time this is you
and me you and me Chris needs to go for
it
ya know yeah Chris needs to go for it
and I just wish Chris would go for it
he's so paralyzed thinking she's gonna
shoot him down it's not gonna happen
which thing well neither if he doesn't
go for it which knowing Chris he won't
unless someone's holding a gun to his
head
yeah taught to kill Bay if I can predict
anything about this horror game even
though it's the butterfly effect I'm
supposed to be very unpredictable with
all of my decisions yes Josh
I just wanted to say
what it really means a lot to me that
everyone came back this year and you
know that you can Sam see it's weird to
be back we're here for you god no it's
so weird
oh I'll be honest it's definitely weird
being back here but I think it'll help
us all put everything behind us you know
hey I'm just being honest with you dude
like being pretty honest it's a little
weird being creepy up here
I mean you've obviously been here for a
while now and haven't turned on it this
is very dungeon like where are you
leading me I my red flags are going off
all over the place I just don't like any
of this why is it squishy why is it
squishy there you're not gonna tell me
what's squishy down there pling
need some porn party company some
serious porn party who bat am I gonna
use this I'll take that yes who knows
when snus tonight's needed baseball in
the snow in the winter silly I mean
we've come up in the summer we would
have the best time the whole
was there mom dad my sister serious
competition out there on the big lawn
I don't know can't go back no reality so
I should I should probably remember with
it is that's a big-ass water heater
gigantic right it tried your best what
can you do you flipped it on enough I
respect that
can I go wander around without you you
know what it was is that bad gonna be
gone you don't need to shine to that
close sign it I am not moving I'm moving
I'm so not moving thanks
nice holding a flashlight
we gotta increase the water pressure
before we get the boiler fire now have I
supposed to
I'm just trying up no all right did I
not do it too quickly enough
all right whoa cool Morissette one
helmet myth that would have been really
awkward if we didn't do that land on
each other's shoulders leave them there
for a minute then shrug it off oh he's
waiting yeah let's see something behind
you
[Music]
don't laugh
Yeah right
seriously
[Laughter]
what no where'd you get the first point
doesn't start
this is the most Awkward of awkward
flirting I've ever seen in my entire
life yes how good what not good nothing
regular about it
let's see we should check it out we
should check it out get the bad pipe
that's about to burst or some problem
with the furnace unlikely really I
wouldn't want this place to burn down to
my watch
exactly Emily could explode it's no good
Hey look a red tag I can't move far
there there we go oh my god
to keep out strangers
what the hell you just got mugged
what why would you do that there's all
this cool movie crap down here what was
I was I not supposed to take advantage
of the opportunity thank you
are you serious were you in on this
good yeah bro yeah okay back to the porn
party porn party porn party joke mr.
weren't they off together they were
together how did he get that thing and
get the costume on and get in the
basement all before they did I don't get
it
oh god now what the hell happened okay
we're gonna stop it there so oh god not
him Perseus lips you've written weirdo
so wait where am i oh god why am I here
either way all right that's all the time
I got for this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm gonna
continue this real soon thanks again
everyone and as always
and the next video maybe he actually
thought I was the real Marky moon little
did he know I was actually